The ceiling of it emotion is a process
that is distinct from having the emotion
in the first place.
So in order to understand what is an
emotion,
what is it feeling,
we need to understand what is an emotion
and an emotion is the execution of a
very complex program of actions,
some actions that are actually movements
like movement that you can do,
change your face,
for example,
in,
in fear a or movements that are internal
that happened in your heart or in your
gut and movements that are actually not
muscular movements,
but rather releases of molecules,
say for example,
in the endocrine system into the
bloodstream,
but it's movement and action in the
broad sense of the term.
And uh,
an emotional consists of a very well
orchestrated set of alterations in the
body that has as a general purpose,
uh,
making life more survivable by taking
care of a danger or taking care of an
opportunity either or,
or something in between.
And it's something that is set in our
genome and that we all have with a
certain program nature that is modified
by our experience.
So individually we have variations on
the bathroom,
but in essence your emotion of joy and
mine are going to be extremely similar.
We may express them physically,
slightly differently and it's of course
graded depending on the circumstance,
but the the,
the essence of the process is going to
be the same unless one of us is not
quite well put together and is missing
something.
Otherwise it's going to be the same.
It's going to be the same across even
other species.
You know there's a way that we may smile
and the dog may wag the tail,
but in essence we have a set program and
those programs are similar across
individuals into species.
Then the feeling is actually a portrayal
of what is going on in the Oregon is
when you're having an emotion,
so it's really the next thing that
happens.
If you have adjusted emotion,
you would not necessarily feel it.
To feel an emotion.
You need to represent in the brain in
structures that are actually different
from the structures which lead to the
emotion.
What is going on in the organism when
you're having the emotion so you can
define it very simply as the process of
perceiving what is going on in the
organism,
when you are in the throes of an emotion
and that is achieved by a of structures.
Some move the chair in the brainstem and
some of which are in the cerebral
cortex,
namely the insular Cortex,
which I like to mention,
not because I think it's the most
important.
It's not.
I actually don't think it's the number
one structure,
a controlling our feelings,
but I like to mention it because it's
something that people didn't really know
about and many years ago,
which probably now are going close to 20
years ago.
I thought that the incident would be an
important platform for feelings.
That's where I started and there was a
hypothesis and turns out that the
hypothesis is perfectly correct and 10
years ago we had the first experiments
that showed that it was indeed so.
And since then a countless.
Studies have shown that when you are
having feelings of emotion or feelings
of variety of other things,
the insula is active.
But it doesn't mean that it's the only
thing that is active and there are other
structures that are very important as
well.
Well,
is he emotion opera?
Very often when you think about how you
react to the world,
uh,
you know,
something is happening to you there.
You're simply going along and your being
confronted by different things,
not necessarily very important or
significance for your ultimate life,
but you are constantly reacting to the
world.
You're thinking about the world in your
acting on the world.
And emotions are engaged when the stakes
outside of your organism are fairly high
in positive or negative directions.
And this of course comes from ancient
times in biology when you were
constantly being subject to potential
threats and to potential opportunities.
The threats were obvious,
for example,
predation,
uh,
or inclement weather or,
um,
physical environments where you would be
like having a precipice,
a or a hole on the ground.
Uh,
the opportunities are also very easy to
see.
They have fundamentally to do with food
and with sex.
And so the motions were placed there in
evolution is incredibly smart devices
that rather than having you think
through the problem,
would deliver a solution and make sure
that you would act right.
It's in a way a contribution to a sort
of on auto pilot that we've inherited
through all these millions of years of
evolution.
So if there is an opportunity,
emotion is going to make sure that you
at some level know that it's there and
that you're going to have the tendency
to act on it.
And if there is a threat,
you're going to be alerted to it.
And even before you're alerted to the
threat,
as such,
you're going to be placed in
circumstances that are likely to make
you either freeze or run away from the
danger.
Okay?
So this is a level of response to the
world that is automated.
It's largely nonconscious.
I mean,
it happens,
nonconscious.
Then you'd take consciousness of it
because once it's happening,
once you start feeling what is happening
and connecting the feeling to what
you're perceiving,
then you realize how hard there's the
danger or ha,
here's the next lunch.
Um,
and so there is a level in which you
will have a way in which the entire
process then is made conscious and
enters your mind flow.
Uh,
and uh,
even at this level,
you can see that the influence on one's
behavior is astounding and it's by and
large,
extremely useful.
It has of course its downsides because
you may be responding to things that are
better not respond to either on the
negative and positive side,
and that you should not take the bait.
You should not,
for example,
fall for every opportunity and you
should not allow yourself to be made
angry,
for example,
or fearful when there is no cause for
it.
Um,
but there is a,
a way in which by and large,
the influences very positive,
uh,
and then it,
it,
the,
the experiences of emotion also have a
way of modeling what your going to do
next.
Because unlike say,
a squirrel,
a who is not going to think much about
his or her experiences of emotion.
We do,
and we have,
because we have feelings because those
feelings can actually stay in memory in
terms of the elaborations that we make
about the feelings,
for example,
using language.
Then we have a possibility of using
feelings of certain emotions for future
planning and that makes a huge
difference.
So,
uh,
for a little animal that doesn't have
much mind,
uh,
and no advanced planning,
it's a way of keeping alive for animals
like us.
It's a way of keeping alive sometimes,
but an even better way of constructing a
view of the world and making sure that
that view is taken into consider
when we plan future events.